1080p became the ultimate goal for
gamers back when the seventh generation
of consoles launched and even the pcs of
mere mortals were able to reach that
holy grail with aaa titles by the time
radeon hd5970 and geforce gtx 480 came
out in 2010. so why are we still getting
excited about 1080p graphics cards in
especially when they cost
what almost 400 dollars
am i in a time loop oh man
not a
maybe if i review it it'll stop or maybe
if i tell you about our sponsor i fix it
do you like to repair your own
electronics instead of having to spend
hundreds on expensive replacement or
repair services find out more about
ifixit's essential electronics tool kit
at the end of the video
[Music]
the rx 6600 xt is a strange release in
many ways
yeah it makes sense to release a gpu
that's less than half the die size of
the rx 6800 xt and yeah it makes sense
that it would use 16 gigabit gddr6 chips
both of those things make it far easier
to manage supply constraints that have
been strangling production
and are projected to continue into 2022
or even 2023 depending on who you ask
no what's strange is the pricing which
we will get to i promise but also the
fact that because there isn't an amd
branded card this time around
amd has made the decision to send
factory overclocked cards to reviewers
which means that everything you see from
this point on needs to be taken with a
pinch of salt sure the card has all the
same basic features it's it got eight
gigabytes of gddr6 memory 32 compute
units and as many megs of infinity cache
and all the goodies that come with rd
and a2 like ray accelerators real-time
ray tracing support but that's where the
similarities between the basic spec and
what they've sent us end and what they
sent us is asrock's seriously overbuilt
phantom gaming d card with a whopping
three fans and as many heat pipes to
handle the 160 watts worth of heat this
thing is supposed to be kicking out the
overclock itself is pretty mild at about
80 megahertz in game and under 20
megahertz at peak boost which amd says
will be typical of other factory
overclocked cards so this atypical
cooler is probably overkill the back
plate for its part is thin and seems to
mostly be for show with what looks to be
a pair of thick boy thermal pads on the
back of the pcb i say looks like because
in order to get the back plate off
you need to take the cooler off and
we've got benchmarks to do before we
mess with the card's thermal
characteristics you know the drill gpu
bench latest updates amd's immediate
family and the two nvidia gpus that the
6600 xt is most likely to take head-on
you'll note we're using more ram than
before dual rank memory is good for you
you should try it helps keep ryzen fit
anyway all our games will be running
1080p max settings with ray tracing
turned to minimum where applicable
starting off with some surprising wins
forza horizon 4 and assassin's creed
valhalla put amd's mid-tier gpu ahead of
nvidia's rtx 3060 ti by about 15 to 25
which is absolutely fantastic
considering the cards are priced so
close together unfortunately this
pattern doesn't hold up as we move on to
other games like final fantasy 14 and f1
2021 where even with ray tracing off the
radeon loses out by about 10 percent
putting it closer to the cheaper rtx
3060.
this gets even worse when ray tracing is
enabled and especially for a global
illumination title like metro exodus
where we see the diminished ray
accelerator count really bring the pain
thankfully global illumination is not
really common yet but it's worth testing
all the same
none of these results are especially bad
to be clear the lowest non-ray tracing
result was still well over 60fps and one
percent minimums and it's consistently
much faster than the rtx 3060 but when
you're forking over 3060 ti money it all
starts to look like an advertisement for
that card instead as always with cards
this low on the ladder productivity
isn't a major consideration but we're
including benchmarks here because it's
very possible that you need something
affordable for work at home and given
that for 20 more the rtx 3060 ti punches
up the trade blows with the rx 6700 xt
it's no surprise that the cut down 6600
xt can't really compete here either even
against the rtx 3060.
that's not to say that there aren't some
amd wins in productivity though even
though the infinity cache is much
smaller with this card its ridiculously
fast speed helps it in memory intensive
tasks like the energy and medical tests
in specuperf
although
chances are this class of card will
never see that kind of workload so
it's a hollow victory
sort of like how our water bottles are
hollow you gotta fill them with victory
you know
ltdstore.com for thermals considering
neither the cooling nor the clocks are
stock and this car is probably not
destined for a workstation we'll do
something a little different today and
use two loops of five laps in f1 2021 to
simulate gameplay and see if that game
clock can endure some heat as it turns
out amd's total power estimate was
pretty accurate with an average of about
180 watts and a peak of 225
well below the rtx 360 ti
but unfortunately also about as far
above the rtx 3060.
the extremely overbuilt cooler does the
job fantastically though with
temperatures hovering around 60 degrees
at all times in our closed chassis bench
it kept boosting too with clocks
throughout the test staying stable at
about that 2.6 gigahertz advertised
maximum
not a bad showing at all but then again
this is a factory overclocked card your
mileage may vary and here's another
weird thing about this launch see these
these pins here as the pre-launch rumors
suggested they're 100 per shell
you can even see where they stop being
connected to anything
yeah this gpu is wired for only eight
lanes of pci express
which
seems like a waste of material like why
have a full x16 card edge connector
filled out with pins
i guess it helps with physical stability
i mean this genuinely threw me for a
loop when i first noticed it but eight
lanes of gen 4 makes sense when you
think about it
not only are they equivalent to 16 gen 3
lanes most gpus at this performance
level won't even begin to utilize the
full bandwidth of a 16 lane slot
this means that you're giving up nothing
to use one of these cards in one x 16
slot and then populate the other with a
dual nvme card or something without
compromising the performance of either
heck if you're not squeamish you could
safely mod the card for use in a server
chassis or something without losing any
functionality the pins simply are not
connected but now
we've got to talk about the price
at 380 for the base model it's a steep
ask when this card was announced we went
into the reasons why this price while
painful makes sense in today's
marketplace
but it's going to continue being
compared to the launch price of the rtx
3060 and especially the 3060 ti which is
priced very competitively at 400
the only problem with this take though
is those prices no longer exist and
arguably never did third parties were
charging well in excess of that before
those cards launched there's no founders
edition for the 36t and third parties
are going to prefer higher margin cards
with the precious few gpus they're able
to get in my opinion
that msrp only really exists as a
contractual obligation to make it seem
like it's cheaper than it really is in
order to undercut the competition and i
suspect the same is true of the rx 6600
xt's msrp2 just look at how much
backlash they got for saying 379. in
fact it seems that they're so concerned
with perception that they wouldn't even
tell us how much this particular asrock
card costs and neither does rock if they
pipe up before the video is done i'll
put the price on screen now all of which
is to say
it's impossible to tell you what the
real msrp of any of these cards is other
than what nvidia and amd say they are
that makes it difficult to put the rx
6600 xt into perspective on the one hand
it's slower than the rtx 3060 ti that is
its true price competitor but on the
other whether that price exists or not
depends on who you ask our
recommendation therefore is this
if msrp matters to you the rx 6600xt is
an underwhelming but not disastrous gpu
you could do way worse if features
matter to you the competition has dlss
at this price point and their video
encoder is better for you streamers out
there and if scarcity pricing matters to
you
well our recommendation as always is to
get it if you can be careful though
we've got a video coming on how scam
gpus are becoming even weirder so be
sure to get subscribed so you don't miss
that and okay i know that people don't
like that buy it anyway recommendation
it sounds like i'm telling you to just
be a mindless consumer i get it but the
uncomfortable truth for both you and i
is that even if you don't want it to
sound move for as long as demand
outstrips supply thankfully i've got
more than enough supply of segways for
sponsors like ifixit thanks to ifixit
for sponsoring today's video the ifixit
essential electronics toolkit is a great
basic kit for new users it gives you
what you need for the most essential
electronics repairs in a compact size
that includes the most popular precision
bits they're all held in place with high
density foam so you can throw it around
without any of the bits falling out
they've got a lifetime warranty so
go ahead and get one today at ifixit.com
ltt
thanks for watching guys go ahead and
check out our recent video on just how
viable old gpus can be for modern games
maybe if you're still rocking an old
flagship you don't need to worry about
these selling out right away you know